a public inquiry has concluded that an
unarmed suspect shot dead by police as
he waited to help two people escape from
a prison van was lawfully killed the 28
year old from tottenham north london was
part of a group that tried to free two
inmates from a security van near
woodgreen crown court in december 2015
but speaking after the findings were
published jermaine's mother disagreed
with the judge
i cannot agree with the judge's
conclusion that didn't that jim mayne
did not die as a result of these
failures
that is a conclusion that i cannot
understand and the judge has not
explained why he has drawn that
conclusion
after seven years of waiting and two
months of evidence we deserve more
with i have instructed my legal team to
advise me regarding the options of
challenging the aspect of the conclusion
by the way of the judicial review
we know jermaine was unarmed jermaine
complied with the instruction to put his
hands up in the air
jermaine's hands were in the air we know
this from the forensic evidence
jermaine was surrendering
jermaine could not have done more to
save his life
well skies sadia chowdhury is in central
london for us and said here why did the
judge decide that he was therefore
killed lawfully
well the chairman of the inquiry uh
attempted to explain why he thought this
was a lawful killing looking at those
seconds and moments before the officer
who's only known by the cipher w80
fired his weapon he said that he
believed that at the time the officer
w80 genuinely believed that
jermaine baker
was ignoring his instructions so
w 80 has said in his evidence that he
had
instructed jermaine baker to put his
hands on the dash or the dashboard
but instead germaine baker's hands were
reaching upwards towards a bag that he
was wearing and he said that he believed
that he could have been going for a
weapon there now the families council
told the inquiry
that they thought that putting your
hands up is a natural thing to do when
you see a police officer approach you
with a weapon and they quizzed w80 on
this during the inquiry and there was an
exchange that we'd heard in the inquiry
where they asked why he didn't wait
until he saw a weapon actually being
withdrawn before firing and he said he
was
worried that jermaine baker's actions
would uh
trump his reaction to that um the
chairman also specified 24 separate uh
specific failings in relation to the
planning and execution of this operation
anchor which was
as you say the the conspiracy that's
been described as a conspiracy uh by
jermaine bacon the two others were in
the car to break this prisoner out he
said that
they had enabled the plot to proceed the
officers had enabled the plot to
proceed and not informed the court staff
or the officers driving the prison van
and they said that had allowed there to
be a risk to their safety and had they
done that they said that the van could
have taken a different route for example
they said it was uh he also said that
they had not shared the details of their
plan with the prison governor had they
done that and the prison
then the prisoner that was subject to
being
taken out could have been moved to a
different prison a more higher security
prison
where
belmar prison which is connected by an
underground tunnel to woolwich crown
court and so there wouldn't have been a
threat of escaping he
listed a whole range of failures in
record keeping so minutes of meetings
weren't taken he said risk assessments
were meaningless witness one witness he
described as singularly unimpressive he
said they didn't obtain legal advice
he said one office says evidence was
wholly contradictory he said to
another's slap dash approach to
potentially if not actually important
information and he described their
attitude towards formality as dismissive
and arrogant he also said that their
determination to achieve a successful
outcome for
operation anchor was bordering at times
on the obsessive
and very crucially he said that there
was no firearm in the vehicle that
jermaine baker was in and he said that w
80 the officer who discharged his weapon
wasn't aware of that hadn't been briefed
properly he had attended a briefing and
i'll read out to you a little bit about
what he said following that briefing so
this is the officer w18 he said at the
end of this briefing my state of mind
was that the attack was likely to happen
and that it would be undertaken by a
group of experienced and dangerous
individuals who would be armed and would
use firearms in the course of the
offense
now w 80 is still a serving metropolitan
police officer and he's going through a
series of court hearings
to defend himself against charges of
misconduct
but the judge the former judge in this
said that had jermaine baker not been
fatally shot then all of these failings
would would not have uh come out and
this operation would have been deemed a
success he said these failed failings
should be should form a loud wake-up
call for the incoming
metropolitan police commissioner who of
course hasn't been appointed
yet